will you give this to your cat
he'd take it he'd take it yeah
hey guys i'm brenda blanco i'm a tasty
producer and today we are doing
something very special
we're gonna make potato cups which you
can eat with your cat as a matter of
fact that's what i'm gonna do with my
cat you guys want to go meet her i think
you do
naya
her actual name is naya papaya and
we got her when she was two months old
right now she's really angry at me
because before i call her fat but she's
coming down naya you want to go back
let's go that's it
[Music]
so i'm standing on my
production chair
this makes up for the height that i lack
which is
a lot
this is basically what i do every time i
have to film
so
i got a mashed potato here and i'm just
going to start adding ingredients and
getting this thing ready hopefully she's
going to eat it
[Music]
i'm going to add peas it's really good
for your cats carrots you guys know this
is good for any creature ham they love
it and
you can't stop that
no it's not like you can just
grab a spoon of salt and add it to this
so now this is when you have to be super
creative the ham's gonna add a little
bit of sodium and now i'm adding a
little bit uh parmesan cheese and uh
hopefully this adds that extra touch of
salt
that was beautiful you guys see that was
like
okay
mixing part is when these biceps show
off all right guys
[Music]
all right let's go
i'm just gonna grab a little bit of this
just so you know the cat's been hiding
under the couch since we got here
hopefully this little piece of potato
will get around it but here
come in please welcome to my freak house
nyaya papaya say hi
right there
maya
i know you're hungry
she's eating it she's eating
she got scared but she ate a little bit
so that's great
that's all we wanted guys let's go
so these are the little cups that i got
can you see this
okay so i have my regular human size and
then kitty's eyes this way you're
avoiding giving them anything that you
don't want like i'm gonna add a little
bit of salt to my cup so you know it's a
really easy way to differentiate between
both of them so scott
if you
had a chance to have a pet
what would it be
you would not consider a cat
so scenario taylor swift shows up
she's like oh my god scott we should
totally hang out and she's like are you
a cat person
oh my god taylor
now it's her turn
[Music]
kitty come on she smells
so good i gave her a shower yesterday
she's ready for her debut want me to
hold her yes
[Music]
she's going to push in
this bread crumbs
then the eggs
please naya please just let me have this
one here we go
[Music]
just one little ball come on
oh god
this is gonna be tough
[Applause]
oh kitty
i told you this was gonna be hard if she
had these walks by that'll be kind of
cool call her from that side
that is cute do one more of those nia
come on
pass pie
oh that's awesome yes not the plan but i
think that's going to give us something
come on naya she's playing with jordan
we can keep mixing here so usually you
would add flour to this mix it would be
like flour egg and then the bread crumbs
but turns out cats cannot have flour so
in this case
we can do the eggs they can do bread
crumbs too but they have to be whole
wheat bread crumbs
and no seasoning they can have olive oil
thank god
anyone who's a cat person or any pet
you're always thinking how can you do
things better for them and one of those
points usually ends up being food
but i just wanted to do something
special for my cats once in a while
maybe it's like their birthday
maybe you're really freaking lonely you
have no one to share anything with
there's the cat also if you're a fan of
tasty and happen to be a cat person tell
me this is not like disneyland like the
freaking dream come true i'm living it
for you
[Music]
oh my god this is the moment of truth if
she doesn't eat this my career as a
crazy cat lady is done
[Music]
[Music]
so now it's just the cat and i
everyone left
and so i'm hoping that
being just the two of us
uh her fear is gonna go away and she
will eat
[Music]
i think that you should experience how
rewarding it is to see them eat
something that you cooked with so much
work effort and love deal with the
hustle and enjoy it because you will
enjoy
[Music]
oh yes
we talked about this please don't do
this to me like otherwise there's no one
there's not going to be a walk in the
park this weekend
it's fine
[Music]